hello and welcome to Android design in
action this week we've got a jam-packed
show we're going to take you through
some of the redesigns of the Google Play
applications and we're very lucky to be
joined by some special guests from the
Android design team this week and as
always i am your host Nick butcher and
in New York we have hey guys Roman Erika
and over in Mountain View we have our
special guest mark owner and do want to
introduce yourselves a little bit guys
hi everybody thank you for having us
here my name is Marco and a lead user
experience for Google Play hi I'm Owen
auto I'm the lead designer on the Google
Play Music app great so thanks very much
for joining us so without any further
ado let's jump into some of the
processes behind the redesigns right so
let's get started so Google Play you're
probably familiar with it but just as a
quick introduction Google Play is the
media offering from google it basically
covers all your content from games to
apps music books movies and magazines is
the place where you get your content is
a place where you enjoy it so today
we're going to be talking about the
redesign particularly there are three
keywords that are going to go across the
presentation is how we design it
responsive how we made it responsive
modular and emotional at the same time
so we had three goals in mind when we
redesign the Google Play suit suite of
applications one was to create
consistency across play to populate
content dynamically and to create
efficient layout on web and device so
creating consistency basically if you
have been using google play in the past
you would have seen that we had a lot of
different ways to represent content and
we thought that we sort of needed to
make it uniform in order to create an
experience that felt familiar to people
but we're content dynamically means that
while we had ways to display content in
a dynamic way across devices and web
there were certain types of content
particularly collections that couldn't
be displayed dynamically for example you
will remember those tiles they were
promoting different collections of
content those tiles had to be manually
drone generated exported in JPEGs and so
we couldn't either propose content based
on your preferences collection based on
your preferences because we had to
produce those Styles beforehand and also
it was a very labor-intensive process
when we talk about efficiently out it's
not about the layout being efficient but
is rather make our work more efficient
so we had to design for a lot of
different screens and platforms
including the web and we just wanted to
have a system so that designers could
define and design their their the
layouts once and apply them to all
platforms so we could focus more on the
new features and the cool stuff rather
than translating the same thing over and
over again so let's jump into the
solution and the design principles that
took us through this journey so
everything starts with cards the
interesting thing about cards is that it
is this atomic element that defines an
entity that defines an object and in
survived and designing for rather than
designing greens which is a sort of
outside in approach where you have
grades when you put stuff in it with
herbal cards being this atomic element
that create spaces from the inside out
so multiple cards shows up on your
layouts and define the content that you
see let me get into some examples
so a card is great because like I said
it contains objects whether there are
applications or albums or movies or
magazines or books or even people or
artists and so forth they basically
contain any type of thing and by being
in the same module we are able to
display things next to each other no
matter what kind of entity they are the
other great property the cards have is
the ability to be in different shapes so
we design a lot of different cards so
that the outs could be more interesting
in hierarchical so we had what we call
tiny cards or small cards or big cards
and cards can also be displayed in
multiple orientations in order to
accommodate different layouts we also
have what we call a medium card or at
least video type of card so there are
two things that have been different
sizes accommodate for one is that they
create hierarchy they can show things to
be more important by being bigger and
also they accommodate for different from
initial informational purposes meaning
they can have more or less white space
in them to show more or less information
for example in the store when we find
something that you may really like we
put in a bigger car which has a bigger
info area in order to display more
reasons about why you may like it or
maybe we can display people that +1 it
and so forth and saying we do on other
applications and you will see that music
later another key element of our design
or canvases so once you understand cards
you also understand how your application
is basically just the canvas on top of
which elements are displayed so it
doesn't matter if the canvas is the
store or music or whatnot the point is
that you have content that is displayed
on top of these canvases somehow our
design tries to be APK agnostic in a way
that you may want you may see in the
future a book in the music application
why not the store is a perfect example
where all the content come together
in one place another great example of
canvases is what we do today in the
movies application if you're familiar
with it when you pause the movie you
basically see the actor that is there
you see a similar movies where the actor
has been participating in and this is
just the canvas it is a canvas where we
display on top of it a personal card and
a listview card with a bunch of movies
in it it just about canvasses the
content lives on top of them another
notion that is key to our design is the
notion of clusters so once you have
multiple cards next to each other
because of the size visual psychology
law of proximity you perceive it as 1 1
unit a cluster and that allows us to
display collections in this way we also
made these collections to be dynamic and
follow that hierarchy that I talked
about before by allowing a cluster to
have different models in them and
because we designed those cards
beforehand to be plug into each other
through Heights they are following the
same structure we can basically display
clusters that have different types of
cards in them and still feel as a unit
as you see here also naturally the
clusters they work across our typical
canvases like phones or tablets and web
and beyond this led us into this
responsive layout philosophy when we
talk about responsive layout we're
talking more about a design approach
rather than the responsive web design so
we're not talking about designing your
website to respond to different campuses
but rather how as designers we thought
about how our layouts will expand across
multiple screen sizes and this is what
we define here is responsive layout and
responsive design so as you see we took
in consideration all the typical
canvases from phones
to tablet 7-inch to tablet 10 inches and
typical laptops we always had all those
canvases in mind and we kept on
designing throughout these canvases
across the whole process we didn't start
from phone or from a particular tablet
the process took us through all these
canvases and all we were thinking about
was how many columns these layouts will
be supported on it's just the number of
column we ended up almost not calling
phones phones anymore but just calling
them four inches or three inches or
maybe two columns layout three columns
layout etc let's look let's get into the
output a little bit and then we will
jump into into music which is a great
example of how these principles are
applied in practice but some examples
that I want to show in these layouts are
for instance this is the store and you
can see how the same types of cluster
scales across all screens in particular
this particular movie is recommended to
make bigger because a friend of mine +1
it and you see how its prominence
hierarchy is scaled across a phone a
7-inch in a 10 inch tablet growing in
size and allowing other content to
display next to it by keeping that
hierarchical relationship on phone you
don't see other content part of the same
cluster just because the space doesn't
allow that but when you get to the 10
inch tablet instead we have a very
beautiful big cover with other related
content next to it which is recommended
to me or talking about modularity we
also applied the same principles in the
store in the way we show our banners in
the way we apply our photography to our
collections for example here you see
that we have enough for photos next to
the content and you see how we show more
or less content according to the number
of columns supported by the particular
device and you also see how the photo
shifts a little bit so on phone is
shifts a little bit to the left in order
to always be centered in that particular
place but this responsive layout this
efficiency is also
apply to the way we started producing
these assets this photography it is
always a 16 by 9 photo that scales and
moves a little bit across all devices
and the same is true even for our
banners finally about familiarity like I
said before we want to be as much as
possible ap care now stick our
experience has to feel just like one
experience and so by making all layouts
look and feel the same you have this
transitional points for example that
feels really natural and smooth for
example in the books application we have
a set of recommendations at the bottom
and when you expand those
recommendations you land into the store
but in reality the view is exactly the
same so the user will just feel like
he's expanding his collection he wants
to see all the elements present in the
collection and he was excited to think
about now in I just landed him to a
different APK so this allows us even to
mix our applications more and I guess
creating some cross horizontal
opportunities across our play
applications finally about familiarity
by applying the same design principles
across all the Play application suite
you basically see how we start
generating a type of brand that happens
to be visible across all all of them
it's just very recognizable is very
playful through the very colored action
bars through this card's type of
metaphor through this grid it really
starts feeling like something they
differentiate from other applications
present out there and it feels very
googley now we're going to talk about
music so I let oh and to continue I now
I'm going to give you a little
walkthrough on how we applied some of
the principles marco was just talking
about to the design of the music app in
specific and I want to start with just
perhaps a provocative idea within the
design community there's this notion
that we should be designing for mobile
first that's very popularly
you know previously maybe people were
designing web apps and then they were
kind of figuring out how to scale them
down to the phone which we realized was
a bad idea maybe we should focus on the
phone first and I think where we've
moved on to as is possibly a next step
in this evolution which is designing for
everything at once so as Marco mentioned
we were thinking about not just the
phone at the 7-inch tablet the 10-inch
tablet at the web and even in music
kate's musics case the TV so practically
speaking one trick that we use to
approach this problem is we found that
if we on a first pass we kind of think
about the phone in portrait and the
tablet the 10 inch tablet in landscape
that this sort of stretches the design
and really makes us think through things
in a way that scales so I'm going to
give you a little demo of the music app
with a phone in portrait and the tablet
in landscape and I'm kind of talk about
these principles that Marco is
mentioning as well as just showing you
some cool things in the music app so
this is our listen now page it's sort of
the home screen and nap the basic idea
of this is you know when you have a
music subscription service and you
suddenly have millions of tracks at your
fingertips it can be a little daunting
to figure out what to play so this
screen tries to be your concierge knows
your tastes and tries to pick what you
may want to play next to make this easy
and this really shows the the grid
system that marco was talking about and
how it scales and solves the problem on
both the phone and the tablet
so what you see here is we have a two
column grid on the phone and the five
column grid on the tablet as well as
different card sizes there's a smaller
medium sized card on the phone with a
daft punk at the top and this very large
card on the tablet and it just brings a
familiar experience to the user between
both form factors as well as making it
easier for us to design and easier for
engineers to implement when we reuse
these grids and card systems next I want
to show you what an artist page looks
like so this is the page for seeing him
they have a new album out now and the
thing that we thought was really
interesting in this layout here is in
opposition to a kind of typical tablet
layout like imagine a gmail app where
you have sort of one column that has all
of the messages and on the right is sort
of an expansion of one of those messages
we decided to go route here on the
tablet where we really stick with just a
one one panel and but we make the
graphics really large and beautiful and
immersive as well as by using the
cluster layout the same one that I was
talking about before an illicit now
screen you can scale up to fill the page
nicely you can also see in action on
this page the cluster model that we were
talking about before that spread out
throughout all of the Play apps where
you can have different sections in this
case related artists and you can expand
them to get two more
next I want to show you our playlist
screen one of the really cool things we
have in the service is we actually have
a team of editors who are sitting around
making these awesome playlists things
like I like this one called intro to
Nordic metal so you can learn about new
genres you don't know anything about or
keep up to date on a genre that you're
really into this is one I've been
listening to lately that's on indie
electronic one of the really nice things
that we came up with on this page was we
wanted to kind of continue that design
that i was showing on the artist page
where we have a big immersive graphic at
the top but we got to the playlist page
right what do we do because the artist
there's a lot of artists on this page
and we struck upon the idea of just
doing this kind of rotating carousel so
you can see many different artists
photos of all the from all the songs
that are in the playlist another
interesting thing here about the you
know the relationship between the phone
and the tablet and landscape is you can
see over here on the song list on the
tablet we've got a little bit more room
here so rather than showing the song
title and the artist name right next to
each other as we do on the phone we
spread them out in two separate columns
on the tablet and you can also bring in
a little bit more information on the
tablet like the song duration which just
doesn't really fit nicely on the phone
another example of this same kind of
principle is in our now playing bar
which you see at the bottom of both the
phone and the tablet which shows you the
currently playing song and gives you a
few controls now on the phone where it's
it's there's not a lot of space we just
have a play button in addition to the
song info but on the tablet we give you
a full you know previous button and next
button and even thumbs up and thumbs
down so you can do some reading so it's
just that you can take the same elements
and just add a little bit more on the
tablet but you still maintain that
consistency and reusing the same
components from an engineering
perspective
what I wanted to call out really quickly
is that this isn't like two separate
apps you know throughout this entire
presentation and demo of subpar you guys
have basically been showing the same app
on a phone and a tablet it's just that
the individual elements in the app the
individual elements within the now
playing bar and wouldn't be the kind of
song list those stretch and those kind
of realign themselves reposition
themselves that's one of my favorite
things about this app is that it's it's
truly responsive designer at the
individual component level yeah that's
really important to our approach a
couple of the things i wanted to mention
one one cool thing we did on the phone
because we we didn't have room for those
next and previous buttons we have these
little touches like you can swipe to go
to the next song it's pretty cool and
the next piece I want to talk about is
our now playing screen
this again shows the idea we were
talking about before where the same
design when you have these large
graphics scales to both both form
factors maybe the graphic gets cropped a
little bit differently but it still is
beautiful and immersive and again you
can you can swipe to go to the next
track on the Now Playing screen it's
pretty nice the last piece I want to
talk about is our q UI this is where you
can see what songs are coming up next
and here there's some other nice
gestures like you can swipe to remove
songs we don't want to hear one now on
the tablet we did a nice little touch to
just customize for the the tablet use
the space well which is just that rather
than making this be a full screen like
it is on the phone the Q we meet it just
be a pop up so you can still say stay in
your your Now Playing screen without
kind of having to leave to go somewhere
else so that's the basic idea is to
design for the phone and tablet and
think about all the other screens at the
same time and a lot of these components
can be reused and scale with just slight
tweaks to come to optimize for the form
factor all right excellent thank you
very much for going through that that's
a brilliant whirlwind tour the cards
philosophy behind a google play and how
to apply it and I had a few questions I
wanted to pick up on land so you said
you're trying to think about all devices
at once when you're designing like
practically how do you go about doing
that mean and do you have like a large
canvas and with all the different screen
sizes on once or how do you actually go
about doing this
do I take on sure so I think one tact is
the one I was mentioning which is when
we're we're going in deep on a design we
may think we may narrow the scope down
at first to the phone in portrait and
the tablet and landscape but I think
another key piece is that we worked on
we worked on the store app everywhere in
great detail at first so this allowed us
to then learn a lot about the patterns
and how they work on the different form
factors and we could bring that back to
each of the different vertical apps yeah
there's a lot to say about the good
technique for having a suite of
applications to be consistent to
basically really invest on one first in
order to get to learn all the lessons
that needs to be learned and to do the
best weeks on the layouts and then sort
of expand that to other applications
there's a lot of code they can be
utilized and that becomes very useful
we're actually moving into a space where
we try to make those those those
components motor part of a framework and
they will be the ultimate goal to really
have these components to be called by
any player application and just
inherited a lot of properties from the
design side I wish you could come to our
office because it's pretty interesting
to see the way we work most of the time
you see people for example working on
illustrator and multiple canvases
representing phones and tablets next to
each other in just copy and pasting
elements from one another see if they
were i think is very important from a
design perspective to have tools that
allows you to see things at the same
time to support canvases and I think a
lot of applications that we use today
have made a great progress allowing for
that oh one of the questions I had was
in terms of how you communicate with
engineers so this is actually something
that we've covered before we've covered
this when Alex Faye Borg from your team
I joined us we just wanted to get your
take so we during the process of
designing
the Google Play client apps as well as
Google Play Music app can share any tips
and tricks or anything like that from
the process of working with the
engineering team so one important thing
for us is to be very specific so without
entering skipping all the details about
how we get to design those applications
in the first place and all the
creativity that goes into it but
focusing on the specs if you wish which
is where we have a very tight
collaboration with engineering we need
to we make red lines we make a lot of
very detailed specifications because you
know it's very important to produce
marks and it's really important to
define all paddings all font sizes
everything that is necessary to make
this layout to be the way we want it to
be but like I said before if you had
these modular places in mind it's really
important to get to a very precise level
of the finishing the first time but
after that is done there's a lot of code
that can be shared afterwards so what
happened is that we had to produce a lot
of red lines and specifications
especially for the store which shipped
first but after that we managed to have
engineering to be talking to each other
and get a lot of that information almost
for free which was which was very
important also we sure is that another
example of your outside in and inside
out so I wrote an outside-in approach so
by going deep and working on the Play
Store and defining you know detailed red
lines different sizes of elements you
are then just able to say use the same
yes else well yes exactly and in about
documentation documents are never enough
and they keep on changing so we also
have a specific website which is where
we post all our materials and they are
more accessible and this is where
engineering can go and get all the
information that they need plus you know
we are lucky we work next we work next
to the engineering team
we we are part of the same team we're in
the same building and so nothing can be
better than face-to-face of course it's
it's it's obviously very hard to get to
the right level of specification by
simply writing documents especially when
you get to motion design and all those
nuances that oh I have shown like the
playlist design if you don't sit next to
each other yeah I think one other thing
I'd add that applies that we really did
in the the google play redesign it just
applies to working with engineers in
general is to get get the engineers
involved really early in the process so
I started meeting with engineers and
presenting you know when we just had
really rough sketches of you know like
the information architecture and and
kind of a rough idea of how different
features would work notnot beautiful
mocks not you know things were your red
lined out or anything but just kind of
the rough strokes and through that we
get everyone's feedback early on and and
also learn about things that might be
technical issues that might we might
want to work around in the design or
tweak to make sure we have a really good
user experience at the end of the day
well thanks I want to ask a quick
question about the awesome use of the
action bar and a translucent background
so hopefully people noticed it in a doe
there but and one of my favorite
features of the app is on the menu
screens like the artists screen for
example you start off with a fully and
translucent action bar and then as you
scroll down the content it fades in a
background color through and for me it
works bring you for making the most of
the imagery as well as you know working
with the action well pattern very very
flexibly can you give us them some
background on how you came up with that
or you know what were your design goals
of that kind of for that piece yeah I
mean I think basically the idea was just
try to we really wanted to focus on the
imagery and by sort of making that the
the action bar be transparent if you're
made the image pop more and be more of
the centerpiece of the screen and then I
don't remember who came up with the idea
of it kind of fading into orange but
roughly it was to solve the problem of
that when you scrolled down you needed
to make sure that you could see the
controls when the picture was wasn't
there anymore and I'm so just want it
being kind of a cool touch to solve that
problem yeah it's something to say about
the action bar I think there's a lot of
ways that we can play with that with
action bars to be too big to be
differentiating within applications and
and this is a very good example and you
have a lot of examples on Android in
general so in play for instance we
decided to put a flat icon instead of
the 3d icon in the action bar we made
those action bar very flashy we just
become invested in them and investing in
the colors that we have at the same time
when you get to an artist you kind of
feel that that is the artist page it's
not the music page and so it has to
belong to the artist and that's why it
has to feel as more neutral as possible
and like I said before the lot of
examples on Android today about
different users of action bar that can
make our layout very flexible another
example that I can remember for example
is the agenda view on a calendar where
the action by on the phone where the
action bar shows one of the items of the
agenda view itself and so it shows the
information present in there it doesn't
have any calendar icon and it's just
part of the informational structure of
the page same goes with the people
application where in the in the detail
in a dinner in a counter color of a
people application the action bar takes
the name of the person and it doesn't
it's not just the empty real estate to
have an apple for them so I really
invite everybody to think about ways
that we can play with the action bar by
still keeping it consistent because that
is really affects usability so it's
important to obviously stick to the
patterns
yeah definitely I think it's one of the
best ways you can bring branding to your
application as well right you have this
this bar there which is persistent so I
think you've done a really nice job in
the Play app so that it's all see a
sweet of you know very kind of closely
like close cousins apps you can tell
that they're designed together in
concert but they have their own
personalities right through the
different colors and so forth so I think
that's a really nice use of the action
bar to bring that branding to each
individual app there's some other tricks
that we made with color that you can pay
attention to for example we have a set
of affordances like the painting icon
and other icons that change color
according to the application you're in
so on music everything is styled to be
orange in books everything is styled to
be blue in magazines everything is
styled to be purple and same goes even
with the touch feedback if you pay
attention to the music app the touch
feedback is actually an orange overlay
well in the books application is a blue
overlay there are a lot of little
touches that we put here and there to
make each application to feel very
playful but also part of the same family
one quick thing I wanted to point out
for the developers that are in the
audience if you're looking to do some
sort of kind of accent color styling of
your app and you know if you get me some
specs or mobs from the designer and says
hey everything should be a certain
accent color brand color you can use a
tool called Android holo color and be
also the action bar style generator to
do that for you right so I think I think
we might run over a little bit but and
there was some wonderful content you
guys are presented to us a thank you
very much for being our guest today
incoming presenting that so that's all
for this week thanks very much for
joining us once again on Android design
in action and we'll see you soon Thank
you Thank readiness by everybody